[Music]
on this episode of travel dares I've
taken Caroline Sabbath epal yeah well
we're gonna learn how to make Italy's
largest mozzarella balls and I'm taking
AJ on a water bike tour of the gorgeous
Naples coastline come join us on our
adventures on this episode of traveled
Aires this is travel there's the show
where we do daring activities all over
Europe and in this episode we're in
Naples Italy it it ah you really for
York are you ready to see some amazing
views oh I'm always ready for some
amazing view great but first you can't
see anything cuz you're going in the
blindfold so I think of amazing views I
think beautiful beaches beautiful
buildings beautiful people so maybe
we're looking in a mirror good one the
views in Naples are unlike anywhere else
in the world and these water bikes are a
fun active way to explore the
breathtaking coastline here perfect your
head is right there
great okay AJ take your blindfold off
because we are biking through the water
on these hi Java code no way this is so
tight
so how do I get on this thing
okay can't dip my feet in the water
okay I'm going oh I can feel the weights
coming in I think we're doing pretty
well you know I love winning you're
about to compete with someone who takes
cycling every week are you sure you can
handle it oh I can handle it Caroline
okay this is your five stars on the line
are you sure oh I will risk it all okay
AJ three two one go
[Music]
[Applause]
I want I finally beat AJ I did it you
peddled very well that was a lot of fun
I enjoyed that race Wow I cannot believe
you what a way to enjoy this nice little
town caroli there was so much fun you
know I'm so I got a good time those
bikes were so relaxing and the views
were amazing so good but it's your turn
are you ready for your clue Mike okay
get ready to put the Dare in Jerry I
think I know what this is I'm sure you
think you know but you don't we are
going to today because Naples is so
famous for
sighs if there's one thing Italy's known
for its food mozzarella was invented
here in the 12th century and we're gonna
learn how to make it the traditional way
right here oh my god
[Music]
we're about to get an exclusive
behind-the-scenes look hella packed area
makes her famous Desiree cheese a lotta
Vinny Vinny Rosato meet Eenie de la mora
tuna being a significant Oh Akali otto a
traverse in russia so mortal Umaga noura
chica wat rua in ilocano questo coagula
dovish Ecopetrol immigration de vente
pronto para ser hecho para for mary lee
mozzarella rachel is its own entity not
a product a caliber llamo so Krista
gonna show us how to braid it as they
were gonna give it a try we get to do
that we get to get hands on to make
mozzarella cheese
[Music]
okay oh my god I can't wait when do we
get to you this right now
yes these are the ones we folded here's
your beautiful brave horse and here's my
not so beautiful brave yes oh yes okay
all right
oh-ho oh my god
that is good this is like an explosion
this is so good I've had mozzarella
cheese my whole life but nothing
compares to this this cheese is so good
I can't wait to take them back to the
hotel
Naples has been such a great time
there's so much to do here and there's
so much to eat Caroline I need to know
my rating so you were so relaxed on the
water bikes and I think you really took
the time to really take in those views
but if you remember correctly you put
your stars on the line when we did our
little race and I won for that I'm gonna
have to give you a four out of five I
expected that you did do really well on
those bikes Caroline as you know you
haven't done too well with the food
there's your omelet was a little bit of
a flop but you braided the mozzarella
perfectly and you've got it on your
first try so for that I got to give you
5 out of 5 right yes AJ I had such a
blast traveling with you and you nailed
all of your dares so this is my treat
oh thanks and I'm about to go to
southern France with my friend Nico well
I think I set the bar pretty high so I'm
curious to see if Nico can top it well
I'm excited for my next adventure
cheers Cheers
[Music]
you